with high profile leave campaigners
including Boris Johnson and Michael Gove
setting up a new campaign to deliver
brexit Labour's former shadow business
secretary chuka Umunna is looking to
hold them to the promises they made
during the fierce referendum campaign
and top of the list of course is the
pledge to give 350 million pounds maybe
100 million more each week to the
National Health Service well mr. Manik
joins me now from West London and a very
good morning to you well whether the
money is going to go to the NHS
eventually or not so the fact is we all
know we we have left the EU and we're
still paying in and we'll be doing so
for several years well that's right it
obviously depends on when the article 50
this famous provision of the European
Union treaties is invoked that starts a
two-year negotiation process but you're
absolutely right Dermot there were a
whole series of promises that were made
by the leave campaign and you've seen
the successor organization to it being
launched today change Britain which is
the conservative supporting website
conservative home has dubbed continuity
vote leave you were right to mention the
350 million pounds per week which we
were promised would go into the NHS
after we have left of course they made a
series of other promises to not least
that we would be able to continue
trading with the European Union after we
leave on the same beneficial terms that
we trade with them now they said that
leaving would enable us to scrap v80 on
household energy bills of course
importantly they also promised that EU
citizens in the in the UK at the time of
the referendum vote would be given the
right guaranteed the right to remain
here in the UK so there were a whole
series of promises that were made which
the organization that I chair vote leave
watch is aiming to ensure people are
held to account on and I use that phrase
very specifically because of course that
you know there will be some promises
that the leaf campaign made that you
wouldn't necessarily want kept but I
think it's important both from the point
of view of the forty-eight percent of
people who voted for us to stay in the
EU but also the fifty two percent who
voted for us to leave that the promises
upon which this campaign which won in
the end were made that people are held
to account on that and school
tonight's to whether they delivered what
they promised and where are you on
giving people another say when the smoke
clears if it if it ever does clear after
all the negotiation is done and dusted
you think there should be some form of
vote well I have to say and this is
going to disappoint some people who
campaigned on the same side as me during
the referendum campaign as you know I
came on your show many times making the
case for us to stay as part of the
Britain stronger in Europe campaign I
think we have to accept the result we
can't because we've now lost complain
about the rules under which the
referendum was fought now of course
there were misleading claims made and
there were myths propagated but I think
in the end what drove me to argue for us
to stay in is because I didn't like the
divisive politics and setting up
different groups against each other
which I thought some I use that word
specifically some in the leave campaign
kind of pedal I don't like that kind of
politics of division and ultimately if
we're to move forward as a country got
to try and heal those divisions and
bring people together so for that reason
I am certainly not calling for a second
referendum now and in fact I've tried to
get a deeper understanding of why those
who voted to leave did vote to leave I
represent a constituency stratum which
is in the borough of lambeth that
recorded the highest remain vote in the
country I went during the summer and
spent a day in the constituency of bogna
boston and skegness with the
Conservative MP there and that's in an
area that record is the higher highest
leave vote now some people think that
all that those who voted to leave is
somehow bigoted prejudice and basis and
you know there are a small small
minority of people who might fit into
that category but that isn't really what
I found in Boston it's a lot more
complex than that and the nice thing in
a way was that the challenges and the
reasons that people voted to leave in
Boston were the same challenges and
difficulties that we have in in Lambeth
so there can be a meeting of minds there
and I think now part of all of our job
and I do welcome the kind of overall
tone of the article that was written in
the Sun on Sunday today by Jesus Stewart
who is heading up this new change
Britain organization is to work out how
we can actually bring people together
but that doesn't mean that all these
promises that were made during the
referendum campaign by the leaf campaign
which was victorious it doesn't mean
those should be just distant discarded
and forgotten but I think there's a real
opportunity here Dermot for their prime
minister because I think she could if
she was clever about this she could
prove both remain people remain
campaigners and leave campaigners wrong
in the course of the brexit negotiations
mr. manner what about your own future
and ambitions you're standing for a
German ship of the home affairs select
committee I am yes I was already a
member of the committee I am a member of
the committee what drove me to put
myself forward for election as a member
of the committee whether you know many
issues that arise in my own constituency
and that the Home Affairs Select
Committee looks on for example stratum
we have one of the biggest African
Caribbean populations in the country and
yet you're more likely to be stopped and
searched to be charged to be put through
the criminal justice system if you're an
effort of an African and Caribbean
background and there lots of other
issues that we're looking at like female
genital mutilation and prostitution
which are also very very prevalent in my
constituency so that's why I'm putting
myself in part why I'm putting myself
forward and to all MPs because the chair
of the Home Affairs Select Committee is
elected by all MPs from all sides of the
house I decided to put myself forward
this week having been encouraged to do
so by members of parliament and not just
on the committee a lot of the members of
the Cote wanted me to put myself aldana
supporting me but right from people
across that ok just when I get a word in
there just examine the in part bit
because it said perhaps this is symbolic
of the so-called big beasts of Labor
heading for other jobs because of what's
going on with the the leadership there
we've got Andy Burnham going from air at
Manchester sadik-khan already in London
are you looking for other ways to
influence things well I always said when
i left the shadow cabinet in September
last year and it was by mutual agreement
of myself and Jeremy Corbyn the leader
that it probably better for me to
support the cause from the back benchers
I always said at that point that I never
subscribed to this view that the only
way to make a contribution in
Parliament was by being a front bencher
whether that's on the minister you know
on the government side or the opposition
side and I look at some of the fantastic
work the colleagues have done over the
years from the back benches where
they've actually changed laws and helped
improve things stella creasy the mp4
walthamstow nawl her work and trying to
clamp down on legal loan sharks or the
deputy leader of the Labour Party Tom
Watson when he was on the back benches
and the work he did to ensure we had
better regulation of the media and the
press I think both those things
illustrate that the only way you know
the only way of making a contribution is
not on on the front bench and you know
for us in the labour party once we do
get the result of the ongoing leadership
contest on the 24 4 sep tember or not
you know hands up I nominated Owen Smith
and I hope he wins that contest but
afterwards we've all got to work out how
we can move forward and work together to
advance the labor cause and most
importantly win the general election
whenever that comes because ultimately
that is why our party was set up we were
not set up to be a protest group or
protest movement and I do believe
protest is important but we were set up
to be a parliamentary operation looking
to win power to implement Labour's
values in office and ultimately that has
to be the goal getting the Labour Party
elected and that requires a broad
coalition not just a small part of the
left of the political spectrum but a
broad coalition of support and sentiment
spanning from the center to the left
under our first past the post electoral
system which I actually would like to
abolish and replace with a proportional
representation system that is the only
option open to us you'll abolish this
program we're out of time mr romona
thank you very much too deep chuka mana
there in West London thank you